michael no don't don't make it harder
than it has to be
holly thinks that this relationship is
over well you know what
i am not going to give up that easy
i'm going to make this way harder than
it needs to be okay kids you all have
been so good and unbelievably patient
so i think you are gonna get some candy
[Applause]
kids just remember
suicide is never the answer all right
why is christmas the only holiday that
can have a message
it is the easy way out you are not alone
what the hell is wrong with you
who wants candy
okay
do you want me to stop dating your mom
is that how we're gonna get past this
cause i will
yes
well that is not gonna happen then why'd
you even offer because i assumed that
you want me to be happy because i want
you to be happy michael let me make this
very easy for you i could give it about
your happiness stop dating my mother
you know what i'm gonna start dating her
even harder what's that supposed to mean
you know what it means
hey shut it yep
i don't need to be friends with pam
i have plenty of female friends my mom
pam's mom
my aunt although she just blocked me on
i am
what's her face from quiznos i see her
four times a week
what did you guys do oh there he is
thought you had gone home already why
don't you go home and come back for the
party
well
we still have to do the exit interview
yes we do
i'll let you in on a little secret i've
been very much looking forward to this
moment
very very much i i have been steeped in
anticipation
toby has been
cruisin for bruisin for 12 years and i
am now his cruise director
and my name is captain bruisin
wow thanks michael can i just say that
of all the idiots in all the idiot
villages in all the idiot worlds you
stand alone my friend hello
hey
hi good to see you here
i'm just having a little extra interview
yeah i know that's why i'm here um no no
no this is very boring stuff why don't
you take a tour have you seen the baler
no no
i'll lick it later
it's part of my job
okay
did you need me to take notes hey fam
stay okay yeah
um
all right well then
i will proceed i just have some
questions that i was gonna ask
um
who do you think you are
toby
yeah
correct
um
what gives what
what gives you the right
um i i brought the binder do you want to
take a little look sure you know what
that sounds good i'll take a little
look-see
here we go thank you
what
would you improve
about
dunder mifflin about this play um
no i'm not asking it i'm just reading it
out loud oh i'd like to hear the answer
well let me see i would um
i guess everything's okay
i made it this far right
what's the point
toby why don't you open your present no
no no no no no no no this hey hey hey
hey this might not be what i think
that i don't even know is in there
because there are a lot of presents in
my car and i don't know which is which
suck on this
what the hell is that michael that's
what do you mean michael
that's not even my handwriting hey
what the hell is going on here
who thought it would be hysterical to
give toby a rock
for his going away gift you did no you
made me wrap it no i thought it was over
the line and i just
is there someone there
who's there i hear voices is somebody
there yeah
is someone here i can't see you
because i'm blind it's jim and pam
michael it is
they're back
oh
oh
oh
pam nope
oh
jim hi michael oh i haven't seen you
since my
accident that i had
when i fell
i fell into the pool of acid eyes first
blind guy
like i'm a squeezy
how do i describe it is a character i've
been workshopping whose lack of vision
gets him into all sorts of trouble
the women in my improv class absolutely
hate him
there's somebody i'd like you to meet
somebody else
who has been to prison
who can tell you what it is
really like
i'm prison mike
you know why they call me prison mike do
you really expect us to believe you're
somebody else do you really expect me to
not push you up against the wall [ __ ]
all right hey hey hey that's just the
way we talk in the clink so uh corporate
just said that i don't want to oh thank
you pam pam can you come in here for a
sec
just have a seat i was gonna call you in
anyway um
you know ryan
um as you know
there is going to be downsizing and uh
you have made my life so much easier
in that i am going to have to let you go
first
what why
why well theft
and stealing
stealing
um
what am i supposed to have stolen
post-it notes
post-it notes yeah okay what are those
worth like 50 cents 50 cents yeah you
steal a thousand post-it notes at 50
cents a piece and you know you've made a
profit margin you know go
run us out of business pam
are you serious
yeah i am
um
i can't believe this i mean i've never
even stolen as much as a paper clip and
now you're firing me
but the best thing about it is that uh
we're not gonna have to give you any
severance pay
because that is
gross misconduct and uh i just clean out
your desk i'm sorry
hey dude just got back from jamaica big
whoop i was in hotlanta that whole town
is waxed yeah that sounds amazing but
you know what the lady jan levinson
wanted to go to montego bay you took the
ice clean
i don't buy it
well i'm looking at a photo right now
and i'm telling you it could be in maxim
they wouldn't give you a subscription to
maxim oh no no okay
well
check this out
i am sending you
some email
you got it no i got nothing
check it again hit refresh
yeah mike still nothing
okay wait a second i sent it to you
at packer dunder mifflin.com
wait
i just got it from somebody else
wow
this is hot damn
how do i get you out of this picture
we don't need to
yes we do what
oh
i did it
thank you
thank you thank you see
i'm still here
we're all still here
oh come on dwight
you